hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become welcome back to another
workout I'm Jenna so and my goal today
is really simple is to get your arms on
fire so we'll be working on your biceps
your triceps as well as your shoulders
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds of rest in between and
the best part is you will not be doing
any workouts okay so what you'll need is
a pair of lightweight dumbbells between
two to three kilos each if you do not
have any dumbbells and just grab a pair
of water bottles so that's not by
warming up our joint and also muscles so
just give me nice shoulder rolls roll
them back good small and let's go bigger
nice so just loosen up the joins feel
your shoulders and now let's go forward
again small circles and now let's make
the circles bigger good and now just
spread your arms nice arm circles and
reverse the movement good and now just
point both arms up I just wait to open
spread your chest and now squeeze them
bring them together spread it out and
squeeze so you should feel the stretch
on your upper back as well as your chest
good so open close open and close now
spread your arms bring them out and
bring it together twist you shoot
through the stretch on the upper back
again open up push your chest out
squeeze it good it's all about loosening
up the joints and getting your muscles
especially your upper body ready for a
lot of upper-body workout trust me at
the end of this workout your arms will
be on fire and good now just shake it
out relax a little bit and just give me
a few shoulder presses without any
weights okay
so reach up stretch up remember to stand
up tall and
as high as you can good keep reaching
few more one more and shake it out
grab your dumbbells or your water
bottles right the first workout is going
to be scare crow squeeze so with both
pairs of dumbbells stand shoulder-width
apart
raise it to the side side raise into an
L raise and then squeeze your arms
together okay so open bring it back down
and down okay so that is your first
workout ready in three seconds let's do
this together
so both dumbbells facing each other
raise it up to the side into an L raise
squeeze it spread it bring it back down
and down good again
up to the side L and squeeze it open and
reverse good so you should feel the side
of your shoulders as well as the chest
working good so do not drop your
shoulders okay always make sure that
you're controlling every movement up
maintaining a nice shoulder level so not
too low or not too high up bring it down
and back down good up again up squeeze
it spread it out bring it down and close
good if you feel that the weights are
too light then challenge yourself and
lift heavier and rest it up shake it out
a little bit second workout up right
Road to front race so again with your
pumps facing inwards dumbbells straight
down
I wanted to lift both dumbbells up to
your chest level bring it down and give
me a nice front raise okay let's do it
up elbows pointed out and front raise
good so elbows pointed out dumbbells
close to your chest back down and nice
front raise keep it up with slightly
bent throughout the workout run raise
palms facing down good there you go this
workout will work on the front of your
shoulders good run race and and up right
row good keep going
ah you should also feel the flexibility
and mobility of your joints as well so
again up close to your chest not too
high up and give me a front raise okay
so just right under your chest level and
back up one more and one more front
raise and shake it on staring will this
work out what you'll need is just one
dumbbell okay imagine that you're
holding a steering wheel and you're
driving your car that's it simple as
that so with both hands grab one
dumbbell point it to the front and
imagine you're driving your car so twist
it to the left and to the right remember
to keep it on straight all the time okay
that's the challenge do not drop your
arms down if you were to drop it down
then this is easy lift it up twist left
to right left to right okay keep your
elbows slightly bent good keep going
whoa your arms should be on fire by now
keep going
twist it left and right left and right
nice keep your hands up do not drop them
right now I can feel your shoulders I
can feel your arms keep them up good
that's one more and drop it down grab
another dumbbell weight the punches okay
so it's a jab punch with weight
beginners you can do this workout
without any weights okay
so step one foot forward your left foot
forward bring both dumbbells up give me
a jab and a punch okay that's it so
twist your body slightly nice straight
jab and punches at your eye level good
so Japan ponch jab and punch good if
your arms are on fire be sure to rate
this workout five stars okay go to the
app store and give us five stars rating
good keep punching left and right
suck in your belly tight in the car
twist your hip slightly and keep working
those arms and you will be rocking
sleeveless tops in no time
keep going nice
get your shoulders on fire
biceps triceps all working together and
just relaxed rolling out the Lisbon who
roll it out relax the next workout is
going to be reverse fly with rotation
okay this is a little bit challenging
so the typical reverse fly is to keep
your knees bent toes pointed forward
bend slightly forward spread your arms
to the side okay this is a reverse fly
with this workout what I wanted to do is
give me a reverse fly at the top rotate
the dumbbells to face up and back down
okay
that slight rotation will work more on
your arms as well as the shoulders good
if this is too difficult then go back to
reverse fly without the rotation okay as
you progress reverse fly rotate back
down good remember to bend from your
waist rotate whoa just slight twist and
rotation it's adding a lot more
intensity to the arms rotate and down oh
okay just drop the dumbbells shake it
out a little bit
next next workout around the world you
can do this workout without any weights
again it's not an easy workout but if
you want to challenge yourself grab your
weights okay so beginner this is the
movement imagine you have two dumbbells
in front of you just lift them up go
around the world right at the top and
again bring them back down for both arms
to meet in front okay so bring it up and
bring it back down let's go with
dumbbells facing front up bring it back
down together up good bring it back down
remember your goal is to keep your arms
as straight as possible down again
tighten your core do not hunch or arch
your lower back down control up straight
arms and back down again up straight
arms if you need to bend your elbows
slightly last one more up
and just relax my favorite tricep
workout kick back okay
so against and shoot it with a pot toes
pointed forward bend slightly from your
waist lift both dumbbells up keep your
arms close to your waist and just bring
and lift the dumbbells back and control
down lift it up squeeze your triceps
control down and again kick it back
control it back down okay so nice and
controlled do not rush the workout
do not throw your arms or use momentum
to leave the dumbbells up okay so nice
and control up squeeze holy one count
bring it back down good up again control
and down very good up nice and control
and remember to lock and keep your
elbows close to your body at all times
good few more up squeeze the triceps
right at the top up squeeze back down
one more up and squeeze
very well done one more workout and you
would get a one-minute break okay plank
twist for this you will need a mat so
get down on the mat with both dumbbells
okay get into a high plank what I want
to do is rotate twist lift one dumbbell
up control bring it back down again
rotate lift the other dumbbell up
control down and repeat good there you
go
so use the strength from your core and
your arms to lift the dumbbell up again
rotate
strong core strong shoulders strong arms
very nice the more you tighten your abs
the better balance and control you will
have do more keep going alternate if you
need to spread your legs slightly wider
to find that balance okay very nice nice
you remember to breathe breathe one more
and relax very well done so that was the
first set now take a short break
grab some water wipe your sweat we want
to go for another two more rounds okay
take this time to adjust your weights as
well if you find that the dumbbells are
too heavy go for lighter dumbbells if
you find that it's too light then push
yourself and lift heavier okay so take
this time to adjust your weight because
what is important is that you push your
muscles in order to see results
ah again check your arms out okay
just relax a little bit right you have
about 20 seconds left relax the
shoulders roll spread them stretch them
out it's a bit twist stretch and bring
them together okay good check it out
I taught you your arms would be on fire
right grab both dumbbells let's start
with scarecrow squeeze good lift them up
to the side I'll race and squeeze your
chest squeeze your arms reverse the
movement and back down up l remember to
keep it a nice 90 degree angle good
again up to the side and squeeze your
arms will only get stronger by doing all
these exercises okay I know that most
ladies we do not like upper body workout
because to be honest it is not easy it
is challenging because your upper body
muscles are smaller therefore it takes a
lot more effort to work on them and to
get them strong and lean keep going
last one spread into the side up and
squeeze and shake it up relax
roll a little bit okay second workout
upright row with run/race okay
this workout is to work on the front
part of it show this as well as your
arms right relax and ready or not let's
go upright row just under your chest and
front raise okay keep your knees
slightly bent as well tighten your core
and remember do not arch or hunch
forward good upright row forward just
under your chest and good spread your
elbows to the side okay again with every
movement it's all about control so up
fuss control it down up again one count
control down good so breathe in and
breathe out breathe in breathe out good
there you go nice nice and controlled
bend your knees tighten your core and
that will help you
to increase your energy as well nice few
more last one
drop one dumbbell okay
staring will so imagine you're driving
the car you're going high-speed you're
racing and you're just being in control
of the steering wheel okay so both
dumbbells in your heads let's go lift it
up all the way do not drop it left and
right
twist left and right do not drop the
dumbbell okay that is your challenge
good and keep the dumbbell at your eye
level so not too low or not too high
higher level good keep twisting left to
right and left to right really rotate
huh oh you're halfway there
keep going feel your muscles keep
pushing to not drop now when it's hard
that's when you hold on and you keep
pushing last few more three more seconds
last two oh my gosh Oh shake it out a
little bit I am extremely sore okay
shake it out let's prep both dumbbells
and let's get into weight two punches so
left leg forward right leg back up jab
punch good twist slightly and again
dumbbells eye level good keep punching
straight punches okay do not drop below
your eye level keep punching nice again
beginners if this is too far too tough
drop the dumbbells and just use your
body weight twist and work on your hips
at the same time good oh I'm so inspired
baby let's go let's keep pushing this is
another new year new challenge for you
okay we're in month two we only get
stronger every month every week you only
get stronger good one more
shake it out reverse fly with rotation
choose your option you can start with
reverse flight without pretension okay
and remember remember to keep your
elbows slightly bent okay that will make
it easier so let's go bend down
reverse fly rotation bring it back down
close it good up squeeze your upper back
rotate your shoulders for your arms
again squeeze upper back showed us an
arm work and back down up rotate good
I can't view you stop right now we are
halfway through the workout
okay halfway through the second set and
you have one more to go
strength training this type of training
is really good to increase muscle
density as well as to burn fat ha
shake it out around the world my
favorite workout it's a love-hate
relationship it's not easy but it's
extremely effective okay
so roll your shirt it's a little bit
let's go pumps facing forward dumbbells
close together
let's lift both numbers up straight arms
bring back down control again up use
your core strength bend your knees
slightly
find your balance again up squeeze
squeeze control down good up and down
okay if at any point this is getting too
difficult feel free to drop the
dumbbells I want you to complete the
workout all right up straight arms drop
it down control few more give me two
more up back down last one more up whew
straight arms good control nice and down
and shake it out right
throw away dumbbells just give me a
little bit of twist shake it out release
that tension on your arms and your waist
let's go for tricep kickbacks both
dumbbells up bend from your waist and
remember keep your arms close to your
body at all times and kick both
dumbbells back kick it back control
elbows nice and easy elbows points up by
okay do not spread your elbows to the
side this is wrong so up control down
kick it back nice and control good
there you go squeeze your triceps right
at the top of one count before bringing
it back down up nice and control
up who keep going your triceps let's
lean up those flabby arms bingo wings
whatever you want to call it let's get
it leap up okay up control down and
relax right find a workout get into a
high plank it's going to be a high plank
twists okay and you will get another
one-minute break after this so let's go
get into a high plank done down on the
floor okay let's twist and lift one
dumbbell up control down twist and nice
and control okay
tighten your core do not Pike your butt
too high up or do not arch your lower
back nice and control find your balance
okay white add it on nice and control it
back it down good again very nice
you're at the end offset number two look
at the opposite side look up twist and
look up less than ten seconds
twist good control
twist last one and relax
oh well well done second round it is
only going to get tougher okay because
your muscles are going to get more sore
so take this time shake it out relax
stretch it out a little bit
drink the water keep yourself hydrated
and let's go
oh one more round okay you got this
keep yourself hydrated all right it's
important to keep yourself hydrated
throughout the workout
okay I am stretching and I hope that
you're sweating with me haha but always
getting to my eyes shake it out a little
bit let's go big circles okay stretch
loosen up the joints twist fifteen more
seconds good
ten seconds left okay third and final
set
grab both dumbbells huh scarecrow
squeeze let's go both dumbbells facing
each other up and squeeze it good you
know what let's just make it more fun
okay
up squeeze it bring it up bring it back
down spread it open and bring you back
down good so we're adding a shoulder
press okay so straight shoulder press
and spread it out bring it back down
good again up squeeze the chest together
straight up back down open it good
there you go this workout it's really
good because it's working on your
mobility it's working on every angle as
well ah keep going squeeze it shoulder
press and give me one more right up
together sure to press up spread it out
and dress it out ha ready or not let's
work on the front part of your shoulders
as well as your arms up right row to
front raise okay so remember to not lift
it too high up it's just below your
chest level and point your elbows back
okay ready let's go up back down control
France race good so suck your belly in
tighten your abs and really work on your
upper body good okay
find that base keep your little body
strong okay keep your lower body
grounded avoid too much of swing okay if
you're finding yourself doing this this
is wrong okay so find your base keep
yourself grounded use your upper body
strength to live the dumbbells up good
few more run/race last one and shake it
out right drop one dumbbell staring real
okay this workout looks so simple so
little movement yet when you are trying
to keep that dumbbell up it really
challenges on your arms as well as I
show this okay so both dumbbells ready
boom arm straight up let's go left and
right left and right you can also hold a
plate and do this movement okay or even
a ball it's up to you whatever you have
at home use that good keep twisting
control nice and control do not rush the
workout okay good keep going halfway
there this workout always gets me just
gets me right on my shoulders and my
arms no matter how many times I do this
workout it just gets tougher man let's
go
few more oh that's one top it out drop
it drop it drop it shake it out a little
bit okay just shake it out a little bit
roll your shoulders a little bit weight
it punches all right let's go grab booth
dumbbells one leg forward
whoo one leg back both dump us up punch
give me a jab and a cross good remember
to guard your face as small okay so keep
the dumbbells close to your face and
punch forward straight forward find one
point and punch straight forward good so
if you're doing this this is wrong key
find one point right in the
Center and punch straight good keep
going
tweets lightly use the strength from
your core and drive it from your hips as
well keep going punch forward good few
more ten more seconds
punch twist twist come on I want to see
those punches good strong punches huh
one more relax
shake it off shake it off every time you
know we put this kind of workout
together we're like yeah we can do that
by the time we get to set number three
it's let's go reverse fly and rotation
okay so reverse fly squeeze the upper
back and bring it back down rotate hover
rotate and back down good hover for one
count rotate and bring it back down nice
whoo keep going
you only have three workouts left okay
only three exercises after this up twist
keep your elbows slightly bent up and
twist good there you go up squeeze twist
back down few more give me one more okay
nice rotation let's go nice rotation and
I am sweating I can see my sweat
dripping right next workout round the
world okay so choose your option with or
without dumbbells keep your lower body
bronzer on the floor palms facing
forward and let's go up straight up and
back down okay again if you find
yourself doing this this is wrong kay do
not swing your body so the strength it's
coming from your shoulders and your arms
okay keep your lower body grounded good
push it up and bring it back down
tighten your core
up and down minimum movement from your
lower body and your core okay good keep
going nice nice and control up and back
down few more up down one more up and
back down
tricep kickbacks shake it out a little
bit I'm circles good stretch it up right
last two workouts let's go keep your
knees bent elbows locked close to your
body tricep kickbacks control remember
hover for one count holding for one
count and bring it back down kick back
and bring it back down again what you
want to avoid is swinging or using
momentum to lift the dumbbells up okay
close your body kick it back nice and
control and kick it back good there you
go keep going up and down very good okay
right see this I want you to lock your
elbows I kick the dumbbells back and
control okay lock it
elbows pointed back at all times good
keep going through more elbows pointed
back dumbbells close to your body very
good
last one more
and drop the dumbbells plank twists to
get into a high plank and twist each
side all right let go let's go
huh let go right let's go I play okay
let's get twist if you need to spread
your legs slightly wider to find that
balance good and look high up to the
fight that you're twisting look up find
that balance bring it back down and look
up good find a workout you got this
you're strong and we get the cooldown
together after this who's excited
let's go up back down you have ten
seconds left
what is times I can say you have done 25
minutes of workout
let's go back down twist down rest it
out good right
just stand up okay no more dumbbells
no more weights let's just relax and
rotate your shoulders and your arms okay
so again big circles to the back big
circles forward
and just slowly bring your heart rate
back down okay
and now spread your arms to the side
with your thumbs move it up okay good
just spread it open chest out push your
chest up you should feel the chest the
stretch on your chest as well as your
upper back and now both thumbs pointing
down for this you will feel more stretch
on your biceps okay
thumbs pointing down all right now open
and close to stretch on your chest as
well as upper back and get open close
good open close it give you two more all
right on this one more on this and now
just shake it out if you enjoy this
workout and you want more life classes
be sure to check out my fitness app feel
on the apps tower Cape download the app
and you get to try it out for free for
the first two weeks you would get daily
live classes every single day to work on
your total body and trust me if you keep
a record consistent you will see results
if your arms are on fire be sure to give
this video a thumbs up subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos workout challenges fitness tips
as well as healthy and yummy recipes all
the best and checkup you